[Music]
we are all sporting our black and gold
the knights of course back at the
fortress for the first game of the
stanley cup
semifinals squaring off against the
montreal canadien
sports director chris matthews is at
t-mobile with a preview and interviewing
some very interesting people as well hi
there chris
how you doing guys i'll tell you what
yeah down to the final four montreal las
vegas
in a huge game one tonight here at the
fortress we are standing out in front of
the
nevada donor network tent out here we
ran into a real cool story got to
introduce you to this
because we found somebody brianna love
who had a heart transplant a while back
and here she is right here
and brenda the interesting thing about
this is you really didn't have any
indication that you needed a new heart
yeah i just experienced some flu-like
symptoms in the summer of
2016 after a long vacation and i thought
it was just you know the junk food i ate
of course on vacation
and so we went to the doctors and they
said i flew it in my lungs
and on july 27 they diagnosed me with
idiopathic dilated cardiomyopathy
or a heart disease and i waited six
weeks in the hospital
and i got a heart transplant on my
brother's birthday and ever since then
i lived in utah and i came back and just
been living life
you know to the best of my abilities and
you know living for my donor chris
very cool you're involved in sports and
now you go see a sport for the very
first time you're going to a game for
the first time
yeah i mean i mean i was introduced and
i was just going to volunteer at this
booth and surprised with this
you know big trip and i was just like oh
my gosh like i've never been to a game
before so it's
just crazy it's amazing well the
excitement the surprise on your face was
cool and drew's the one responsible
drew tell us about what you do not only
for people like brianna but 21 others
here yeah so i
started 21 as golden to send 21 kids to
the knights games who have never been to
a game before during playoffs
and i just saw an opportunity because 21
is our year 21 is vegas
it's all about it we're gonna win and i
just thought that
it'd be cool to send kids who have never
been to bend before
so you're doing it with your own money
you're buying tickets with your own
money you bought tickets for
brianna here she's going to see your
first game the joy on your face when you
see
their surprise must be cool it's been
amazing and i thank the local
organizations that have been helping out
with this just coordinating everything
the
nevada donor network the boys and girls
club and it's just been awesome to be
able to do this provide
these opportunities for kids who really
haven't had that opportunity before
well can you give me a big go knights go
you guys go nights go
let's do it together come on ready three
two
one go nice go all right well good luck
hey drew appreciate all you do there
needs to be more people in the world
like you
enjoy the game brian it's going to be a
blast our first game ever
let's now send it to the other side of
toshiba plaza kevin martin has more with
some fans here getting ready for big
game one kevin
yeah thanks chris we are actually under
two hours from the puck drop of game one
of the stanley cup semifinal of course
between the golden knights
and the montreal canadiens and you know
it is
hockey in the desert playoff hockey in
june it is toasty
but their fans are not straying away
that's for sure i found two golden
knights fans all the way from salt lake
city
alex and jeremy you guys are actually in
town to play a hockey tournament
yourself but you're also enjoying the
game
how excited are you to be here for game
one of the stanley cup semifinal we're
so excited it's our first ever golden
knights game
and we've been absolutely loving the
ride that we've seen the last three four
years
and just the support we see from the
vegas fans has just been amazing
and jeremy you mentioned it's your first
game you've probably seen the atmosphere
on tv you've heard people talk about it
what are you expecting in there with 100
capacity for the semifinal oh just
absolute madness like we're so excited
just
see the atmosphere see it loud and
exploding you know
canadians haven't been able to get fans
so we're excited for that to mess them
up tonight and just
lose our voices well i'm excited for
youtube because they told me before we
went live on air that they actually have
played
five hockey games before coming today so
it's time to relax
can you guys give me a prediction before
game one i'm thinking it's going to be
3-1 golden knights 3-1 i like it
yeah stone starting it is off and marshy
finishing up
stone and marshy with the goals all
right 3-1 golden knights
they're predicting a game one win of
course we'll continue the coverage
right here outside of team t-mobile
arena excuse me all day long leading up
to puck drop
at six o'clock reporting live on toshiba
plaza kevin martin 8 sports now